Newtonian determinism says that the
universe is a clock a gigantic clock
that's wound up at the beginning of time
and it's been ticking ever since
according to Newton's laws of motion so
what you're going to eat ten years from
now on January 1st has already been
fixed it's already known using newton's
laws of motion
Einstein believed in that Einstein was a
determinist does that mean that a
murderer
this horrible mass murderer isn't really
guilty of his works because it was
already preordained billions of years
ago nine sign said well yeah in some
sense that's true
even mass murderers were predetermined
but he said they should still be placed
in jail Heisenberg then comes along and
proposes the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle and says nonsense there's
uncertainty you don't know where the
electron is it could be here here or
many places simultaneously
this of course I'm Stein hated because
he said God doesn't play dice with the
universe
well hey get used to it
Einstein was wrong God does play dice
every time we look at an electron it
moves there's uncertainty with regards
to the position of the electron so what
does that mean for free will it means in
some sense we do have some kind of free
will no one can determine your future
events given your past history there's
always the wild card
there's always the possibility of
uncertainty in whatever we do so when I
look at myself in a mirror I say to
myself what I'm looking at is not really
me it looks like me but it's not really
me at all it's not me today now it's be
a billionth of a second ago because it
takes a billionth of a second for light
to go from me to the mirror and by